[Musique]
tout le monde est là ça va commencer
c'est la magie dans ce sens là gardien
d'haragama bras
patrick erard c'est noël
tu sais c'est noël hop une boule de noël
un passing pour un arbre de noël est
très jeune et magnifique domaine
mais si tu veux maintenant peut essayer
une goulée deux ans passés exactement ce
qu'il faut pour mettre sur les nerfs de
noël a fait il faut beaucoup mais
peut-être que la couleur ne te convient
parfaitement
il en faudrait une rouge nouvelle wii ah
bon mais si tu veux me lancer vraiment
pour toi hein attention attention
et voilà son bien c'est à dire gérard
est très jolie ta boule mais n'est pas
si brillant
elle n'est pas sérieux alors écoute
vraiment pour toi je vais accentuer la
voyant situe attention attendait tu vas
te brûler un petit geste est là
peut-être alors là où 1 2 3 et la boule
et les magnifiques tabou bien oui tu
peux la mettre sur l'arbre c'est fait
très bien copieux dit dans cette bougie
qui te brûle les moustaches la veine et
ben tu voyais callas ou fléchir et oui
parce que sinon tu vas avoir vendu à les
[Musique]
attentats
voilà elle était d'un train hier c'était
très bien parfait comme il l a pas l'air
d'être complètement et alors la regarde
pas l'état elle se rétablit par magie
alors non non non non ça y est j'ai rage
l'état s'il était correct mais j'ai
mieux c'est depuis juin le broyage
tachnag à seulement 20 la nature avec
une bien mais on va placer cette
violence je le sapin ça te convient
et oui tiens oui mais non elle est trop
longue et on en repère oui mais quand on
envoie la sphère plus petit
voilà ce que par exemple comme ceci va
te conviendrait annonce gérard basset de
voix trop petit ces deux fois oui tu
sais que tu as des ennuis parce qu'en
vérité c'est pourtant maintenant
impossible de la faire revenir comme
avant ou alors en employant la magie
regarde bien oui sinon je compte 1 2
abracadabra comme tout à l'heure la
guirlande est entière bien solide et
elle est très jolie en pacha gerra
[Musique]
débat
mais
[Musique]
nos problèmes
vous
et
[Musique]
vous
le père noël
at on raconté
aujourd'hui un petit
[Musique]
hadji
un grand hugo devenu compliqué
aujourd'hui aux attentes aux radios
[Musique]
gc ca eric
oui
[Musique]
en
où
[Musique]
un main
où
oh
en
[Musique]
aof hi et bien oui
l'ofs oui et bleu vous avez vu ça c'est
vrai qu'il est bleu mais ce que vous ne
savez pas c'est que la poule aussi était
bleu rocher combat juste et vrai mais si
ce n'est que cela on peut le changer un
an à huy ah oui c'est vrai regardez bien
une simple carte à jouer je l' approche
au dessus de l'efs
abracadabra wallop et voilà ça c'est une
couleur qui vous plaît orchies doublé
mais au bon alors là bien sûr
non mais en vérité c'est un petit truc
que je peux vous expliquer ses seins
parce qu'elle sait vraiment par un truc
très difficile à faire regarder vous
prenez une balle de ping pong c'est cet
ensemble mais enfin et puis le truc le
truc regardez-le et au fond du cocotier
h il ya un truc mais oui c'est un ballon
un ballon qui est là enfin il n'est pas
tout à fait dans cet état là au départ
je vais vous montrer regarde vous prenez
donc une balle de ping pong et un ballo
un ballon que vous prenez de la couleur
que voulait par exemple la bombe
moi j'ai pas le temps de chercher j'ai
pris un jaune personnellement j'avais
appelé au bas alors là c'est très facile
alors on écarte le ballon c'est un petit
exercice pas très facile cette bouée des
jeunes amis pascal
mais la balle à l'intérieur voilà à la
balle est placée à l'intérieur et là on
tire dessus sur le ballon en tournant ce
qui encore ce qui est le mieux et vous
et à ce moment là évidemment il faut
arriver à bien attacher avec un morceau
de fil comme ceux-ci ap
ici vous couper tout ce qui dépasse et
vous obtenez ainsi un petit ballon bleu
que j'ai là ici voyez-vous avec un petit
bout qui dépassent ce petit bout qui
dépasse vous le placez vers le bas et
ensuite vous avez une carte ce truc et
quand elle est constituée de deux cartes
à jouer que les l'une contre l'autre
avec au milieu tenu par la colle une
petites épingles qui dépasse la pointe
dépasse d'un millimètre
j'avais produit les quand vous tapez
regarder ce qui se passe et bien
hop tout dans le fond du verre mais bien
sûr pour que vous me rendiez mieux
compte j'ai apporté une grosse boule un
gros que tu y es une grosse qu'une fois
leur poule verte
là vous allez le voir au ralenti
regardez bien parce que sur la grosse
boule ça descende plus lentement
regardez bien vous frapper comme ceux ci
et au moment où le ballon décembre voilà
alors là évidemment comme c'est très
gros que la boule est lourde
vous ne l'avez pas vu rentrer car en
réalité tout rentre comme ceux ci à
l'intérieur et vous ne voyez plus rien
comme c'était le cas au départ c'est
d'ailleurs pouvait inventer une histoire
autour de saint pascal
je crois que pour noël toi tu as prévu
quelque chose de différent alors steve r
j'ai construit un bonhomme de neige mais
il faisait très très froid et ce qui
n'est pas normal ce petit avait la tête
tout rouge en plus bel âtre ont vu
germain ordinaire correcte toi c'était
ma vitesse bonhomme va naître je t'en
prie pas si les gens continuent alors
j'ai pris mon marteau magique
1 2 3 regardez les revenus comme au
départ après des douleurs à cette boule
irait très bien ici sur le sapin non
derrière des rires comment la et noah au
moment où il ya une étoile dans l'eau ou
alors il faut retirer les toiles un
dakar cheikh des tensions géopolitiques
mal et très généreux mais où est ce
qu'on va la mettre cette étoile on va
peut-être le maître ici non plus un an
kréol la wii oui non si non comment non
sur l'arbre sur l'arbre pays
mais oui mais elle n'y est plus il faut
la paix sur la vie réelle moi je ne veux
pas la remettre sur la je vais la
laisser d'accord attention
sachez une étoile filante
[Musique]
où
on
bon
en
[Musique]
à
où
on
[Musique]
à
on
[Musique]
oh
où
[Musique]
et
donc
d
[Musique]
et
il
[Musique]
oh
nous à la prochaine loi